the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I want to give a quick review so that we
can launch into some more technical
stuff today we started talking about
this reaction for boron Neutron capture
therapy was the focus of today's lecture
and I want to get this one up on the
board since I'm going to move to
different slides later we had boron 10
captures a neutron and becomes lithium-7
helium 4 there's a gamma ray and there's
going to be some Q value or energy
either released or consumed in this case
released in the form of the kinetic
energy of the recoil products as well as
the gamma ray energy so let's also give
a quick review of the Q equation since I
think we covered that last week do you
remember if you have a general system of
let's say a small initial nucleus I
firing into a larger nucleus capital I
after the reaction off comes some small
final nucleus and some large final
nucleus if I were to draw these arrows
to scale the little one would probably
be moving faster then we can defit we
can figure out how much mass and kinetic
energy
each of these nuclei are by just
conserving everything so we can write
let's say the mass of nucleus I C
squared plus the kinetic energy of I
plus the mass of big IC squared plus the
kinetic energy of big I has to equal the
mass of little FC squared plus the
kinetic energy of little F plus the mass
of big FC squared plus its kinetic
energy and what this tells us is if the
total amount of mass or the total
kinetic energy change they've got to
exchange energy kind of equally so we
can write the difference in mass or
energy by just let's say taking all of
the mass terms and putting them on one
side so we can say that list I say
everything here is multiplied by C
squared we have M i+ m I minus M little
F minus M
big f has got to equal the sum of the
final kinetic energies minus the initial
ones which we also call this Q value and
so by getting the difference in the
masses or the kinetic energies at the
end you can figure out whether this
reaction is exothermic or endothermic if
you remember we said if Q is greater
than zero it's exothermic if Q is less
than zero it's endothermic in a nuclear
reaction like a chemical reaction
you've got to input extra energy into
the system beyond just the rest masses
of the particles to make an endothermic
reaction happen for example since we
found out that this BNCT reaction is
exothermic you can make it go the other
way but you have to impart kinetic
energy to one or both of those nuclei to
overcome the Q value that let's see yeah
to overcome the Q value that you'd get
and I want to put up a couple of other
terms just to quickly review we started
looking at the table of nuclides we
learned how to read it specifically to
find things like excess mass and binding
energy the definitions for which I want
to leave up here on the board so we had
the excess mass which again doesn't have
a physical significance it's the
difference between the actual mass of a
nucleoid and the integer approximation
of its mass just from the number of
protons and neutrons and the binding
energy since some of you asked for a
nucleus uniquely defined by its total
mass number a and number of protons Z so
let's say this is a functional quantity
because you can have any nucleus with a
certain number of protons and a certain
number of protons plus neutrons would be
the sum let's see of it's the sum of its
individual nucleons
- its actual mass which also is a
function of Z and a or its proton number
and its total atomic mass number so
let's leave these things up on the board
[Applause]
while we move into some new stuff so
back to where we were on Tuesday we
wanted to figure out well how do we
calculate this Q value you can do it any
of three ways you can use the masses
like we have over here so the masses in
AMU are atomic mass units times C
squared gives you the Q value in MeV or
the difference in kinetic energies gives
you the Q value in MeV although you
don't usually just know these off the
bat especially for the final products or
you can use the binding energies because
the binding energy is directly related
to the maths additively you can
substitute in binding energies here and
you'll get the same thing and so if we
have the table of nuclides you can act
you can either use the mass the atomic
mass of any nucleus or it's binding
energy and just look it up directly the
thing with the fewest steps is just to
use the binding energies because those
are already given an MeV or ke v and
then it's just an addition subtraction
problem if you use the masses don't
forget to multiply by C squared and
remember our conversion formula which
should not be rounded which is this
right here again 931 point four nine not
931 not even 931 point five or else
you're off by 10 kilo electron volts and
so then the question is alright let's
try to calculate the Q value from this
reaction I have the individual energies
and kinetic energies up here but just so
we have a worked out example let's
actually do this so the Q value of this
reaction should be the binding energy of
lithium seven plus the binding energy of
what do we have helium four minus the
binding energy of boron ten minus the
binding energy
of a neutron now first of all the easy
one what's the binding energy of a lone
neutron let's call it out zero yeah a
lone nucleon is not bound to anything so
that's easy that's zero and we can just
use the table of nuclides to look up the
other three luckily I've got it live
over here so let's just punch these in
will have boron 10 and our binding
energy right here is 64 0.75 MeV
let's look up helium 4 good that's
showing up on the screen I think I'll
make it bigger so it's easier for
everyone to see the binding energy is
twenty eight point two nine six MeV and
notice everything is already in MeV so
this is nice and easy to deal with and
lithium-7 thirty-nine point two four
five
plus minus minus zero MeV let's see
actually I think my signs for EXO and
endo are backwards let me fix that right
now because the idea is if you release
energy there we go sorry about that no
wait a minute let's calculate this out
figure what we get and again I can't do
six digits in my head but I will do it
as fast as I can here two for five plus
twenty eight point two nine six minus
0.75 indeed two point seven nine MeV I
had it right the first time so good
shouldn't second-guess myself
cool
[Applause]
so now we know the total Q value of this
reaction and I'll bring the reaction
back up here we also know which you can
find from measurements that the gamma
ray comes off with an energy of zero
point four 8 MeV leaving let's see how
much leaving 2 point 1 3 MeV for the sum
of the kinetic energies of the lithium
and the helium nucleus so let's say T Li
7 plus T for helium now the question is
how did I get to those numbers for the
split between the kinetic energies of
those two anyone have any idea yeah yep
so it's definitely related to their
relative masses more specifically we
have this conservation of energy
equation but we've still got two
variables in one equation we need a
second equation that certainly does
relate to mass yep you can relate their
momentum so we can say that if this
initial kinetic energy of boron and of
the neutron was approximately zero then
it's like these two nuclei lithium and
helium were kind of standing still and
all of a sudden moved off in opposite
directions which means they've got to
have equal and opposite momenta so let's
say the absolute value of the momentum
of lithium has got to equal the absolute
value of the momentum of helium this is
our second equation where we'll use the
first one to figure out what are the
relative kinetic energies and so we're
going to use a quick trick to say if
momentum equals mass times velocity we
can also say it equals the kinetic
energy which is one-half MV squared and
then multiplied by things in order to
make it MV so we can multiply by two
let's make a little bit of space here if
we take the kinetic energy multiplied by
two multiplied by M and take the square
root
we have tea let's say that would give us
2m squared V squared inside the square
root gives us M V so now we can take
these expressions and we can say that
the root to mass lithium T lithium
equals root two mass helium T helium and
they both have a square root of two we
can square both sides of both equations
and we end up with massive lithium T
lithium equals mass of helium T helium
now we take this equation rearrange it a
little bit let's just call that Q to
keep things in variable space and we can
say that T helium equals Q minus T
lithium we can take this T helium stick
it in here we end up with M lithium T
lithium equals the mass of helium times
Q minus T lithium there's a missing H
right there there we go and then from
here oh good we've got some blank space
right here let's see so we'd have I'll
do all the steps equals mass of helium
times Q minus mass of helium times T
lithium and we're solving for T lithium
so we can put this term over on the
other side so let's say T lithium times
the mass of lithium plus the mass of
helium equals Q times the mass of helium
then we can just divide both sides by
the sum of those masses
those two terms cancel and we're left
with the expression for the kinetic
energy of lithium which is the mass of
helium over the sum of the masses times
the total Q value looks like the two of
those might actually be backwards huh
because the lithium one should be
smaller I'll correct that for the notes
when I put them up online because this
ratio should be smaller than 0.5 Q but
at any rate this is how you actually get
them and I want to point out something a
little flash forward to some of the
decay that you're going to be looking at
in terms of nuclear decays let's talk
for a second about alpha decay in alpha
decay you have a lone nucleus sitting
around and then all of a sudden it emits
a helium nucleus as well as a recoil
nucleus and one of the questions that
came up a lot last year is why isn't the
Q value of an alpha decay reaction let's
just write one up on the board possibly
one that you'll be dealing with very
soon hands on uranium-235 can
spontaneously go to a helium nucleus
that's 92 plus looks like 92 31 what
comes before uranium I think that is
thorium although I wouldn't yeah I think
that's thorium and the idea here is that
there's some Q value associated with the
kinetic energy of both of these but it's
not the Alpha kinetic energy because the
thorium nucleus would have to take away
some of that kinetic energy and I want
to show you this on the diagrams so
let's look at u-235 and we can see that
it has an alpha decay to thorium 231
awesome got the symbol right and it has
a decay energy of 4.6 7-9 MeV let's take
a look at the diagram which actually
lists all of the possible alpha decay
energies of which there are
many have to zoom out a little bit there
yeah anyone have a question okay
so notice that the difference in energy
levels is four point six seven six MeV
and if we look at the highest energy
alpha ray it's less than that
and that's because just like we showed
up here the thorium nucleus has to take
away some of that kinetic energy to
conserve both energy and momentum so
this is a question that came up quite a
few times last year and I want to make
sure you guys don't get tripped up like
this so again I think I've said it every
single day and I'll say it again because
it's the next day is make sure to
conserve mass energy and momentum that's
the whole theme of this class yes should
have been 2.79 - oh did I do a little
mental math mistake that should be oh
yeah
no a little dyslexia thing 3-1 yep
there we go thank you
cool okay is everyone clear on how to
calculate Q values from nuclear
reactions using either kinetic energies
which you won't typically know or masses
or binding energies which you can look
up directly from the table of nuclides
yeah oh this one yep
so I took this expression right here
which is to say the Q value has got to
be the sum of the kinetic energies of
the lithium and helium nuclei rearranged
it thusly to isolate ah there we go
yep to isolate the helium kinetic energy
and then substituted that expression in
here to get this one right there yep so
this way we have in this case we had
let's say two variables and three
unknowns but because we have this
equation relating them we're left down
with two variables two unknowns and we
can actually solve this thing yep yeah
good question yes that's something
either I tell you or you would measure
let's say let that's just for
completeness to say all right this
activist reaction actually gives off a
gamma and I want to give the right value
for the kinetic energies and we'll get
into what gamma transitions are allowed
and then how you measure them in the
next couple of weeks actually yes
they're the same one actually oh I see
that's a good point
so this wouldn't really BQ would it but
it is the sum of the kinetic energies
this is like Q minus the gamma ray
energy let me stick that in there l I
yep
yeah good point okay any other questions
before I move on so we're gonna get into
a universal formula to predict in a
so-so way what the binding energy of any
given nucleus will be and start looking
at stability trends so you can predict
just from the number of protons in the
number of neutrons how stable a nucleus
will be with a few exceptions which we
will go over and this is what's referred
to as the semi empirical mass formula so
I'm going to erase some stuff does
everyone got the notes on this bottom
board right here okay let me know when
you're ready and let's see yeah I don't
want to make sure I move at your guyses
pace
let's say going to have a graph of
binding energy per nucleon versus
nucleons well anyway I'll leave that up
there and I'll do the work on this board
right here so let's say we wanted to
figure out a way to graph or to predict
the binding energy per nucleon so I have
this binding energy term over a where a
is the total number of nucleons as a
function of the number of nucleons in a
generalized way not accounting for magic
numbers or anything else that we'll get
into pretty soon and I I don't like the
term magic numbers but that is the
parlance that's used in this field so
I'm going to stick with it
let's try and think about if you imagine
the nucleus as a kind of drop of liquid
and one of the other words for the semi
empirical mass formula is called the
liquid drop formula or the liquid drop
model it assumes that the nucleus takes
the shape roughly of a liquid drop and
you can kind of treat some of the energy
terms accordingly this is why I have all
the different colors of chalk out for
this makes it a little visual easier to
see so let's start writing a general
expression for the binding energy as a
function of a and Z and start thinking
about what sort of terms would add to or
decrease the stability of a given liquid
drop nucleus where all the nucleons are
just kind of there in some sort of
floating crazy Coulomb back strong
nuclear force soup first of all as you
add nucleons to a given nucleus what
tends to happen to the binding energy in
general without knowing anything else
assemble more nucleons you convert more
mass to energy and you end up increasing
the binding energy so let's say the
let's call this the volume term as you
increase the volume of this liquid drop
its total binding energies to start to
increase so let's say there's some term
that's going to be proportional to a the
number of nucleons
that's in this liquid drop and we'll
draw this let's see if I can do the
trick right yes I love doing that if we
were to graph binding energy per nucleon
as a function of number of nucleons for
this term it would just be a flat line
because it's related to a and there's
going to be some constant which we're
going to call the volume constant that
says well there's going to be some
relation between the actual amount of
stability gained and the number of
nucleons we don't know what it is yet
but what we're really concerned with is
the functional form of this thing it's
proportional to a next up what also
happens to a liquid drop as you increase
its volume what other parameters do you
increase exactly the surface area the
idea here is that if this liquid drop is
made of all sorts of different nucleons
and let's pretend that they're like
atoms in a crystal and they're all
binding to each other the ones on the
outside aren't bound to as many nucleons
as the ones on the inside and so the
more nuclei there are near the surface
as opposed to inside the liquid droplets
say inside some little radius where all
it sees around it are other nucleons
then they're not quite as bound and how
does the surface area of a liquid drop
scale with its volume to what function
are to what exponent two-thirds I mean
let's let's take a quick look at the
volume of a sphere is 4/3 PI R cubed and
the surface area of a sphere is 4 PI R
squared so if you want to get some
expression for how does area scale as
volume
I said cube then I wrote squared it's
gonna end up looking like something
times R to the two thought's see oh yeah
I'm sorry that's not the expression I
want to write but the idea here is it's
going to scale with R to the 2/3 so
let's take a different color
and say we're gonna have some surface
term times number of nucleons to the
two-thirds and if we then adjust this
formula to also take into account this
surface area term which is to say for
very small nuclei there's a lot of
nucleons near the surface and as the
nucleus gets bigger and bigger more and
more of them are in the juicy Center and
don't know they're near the surface we'd
have some modification that looks like
that
now I'm gonna race the stuff over here
cuz I'm running out of room now these
nucleons aren't just sort of untagged
anonymous nucleons they're either
protons or neutrons and what happens
when you try and cram a lot of protons
into one space yep they want to repel
each other by Coulomb back for PSA's and
so every proton let's pick a different
color for the columbic forces and that
should be a minus if I want to stick
with all the notations there's going to
be some other term to account for the
fact that the nuclei specifically the
protons are trying to repel each other
so in this case it's going to be
proportional to let's say the number of
protons that we have and every proton
should feel a repulsive force from every
other proton so let's say it's times Z
times Z minus 1 so that every proton
feels the force of every other proton
except for itself and that's gonna be
mediated by the total number of nucleons
so if there are more neutrons in the way
it won't be quite as bad and there's
going to be some other we'll call it AC
for the Coulomb Bukh term and that will
say that as you make a bigger and bigger
nucleus you start to get more and more
Coulomb Bukh repulsion trying to rip it
apart so if we were to then modify the
purple curve oops
trying to get it to go the same as the
nucleus gets bigger I want to make sure
it's really to scale
ish as the nuclei get bigger and bigger
it's gonna be a little Len little less
stable and already we're starting to get
a curve that is getting close to looking
like the binding energy curve from the
reading but there are a couple more
terms to reckon with so let's pick a
fourth color what other sort of trends
did you notice in the reading about the
stability of different nuclei let's say
you were to take a common nucleus like
carbon-12 it's got six protons and six
neutrons and it's exceptionally stable
what about carbon six a nucleus of just
six protons doesn't exist is
exceptionally unstable what about carbon
24 18 neutrons six protons sounds stable
or not not at all so there's some sort
of asymmetry term going on when the
number of protons and neutrons is
roughly in balance especially for light
nuclei the nucleus tends to be more
stable so we can write some sort of term
let's call it a an asymmetry term that
relates to the number of neutrons minus
the number of protons and in this case
for reasons I'm not going to get into
but are derived in a reference in your
reading there's a squared on it but
suffice to say if the number of neutrons
a number of protons are equal then the
nucleus is predicted to be pretty stable
and this works out quite well for light
nuclei it starts to break down a little
bit for heavier nuclei and then divide
by the number of nuclei that there are I
also see I'm missing a 1/3 because let's
say this nucleus has a volume that
scales with roughly the number of
nucleons then the distance of that
Coulomb back force is going to be like a
to the one third or the radius of this
nuclear drop so let's take the asymmetry
term that's going to give us a further
modification slightly downward and
finally there's what's called the
pairing term what's the last color I
haven't used
this pairing term Delta and this is not
a smooth function it's a piecewise
function that depends on whether you
have an odd or an even number of each
type of nucleon protons or neutrons and
so what this means it's going to add a
little bit of jaggedness to the
beginning of the curve and equal out in
the end because this Delta term can be
something like plus let's call it an a
pairing and it scales with the square
root of a or minus or 0 depending on if
the nuclei are odd odd like odd number
of protons odd number of neutrons even
even or odd even now I know that the
derivation is a little hand wavy that's
why we call it semi empirical we're
taking each of these additive terms and
saying it kind of comes from a fairly
okay little poor approximation of the
nucleus but what we end up with is a
formula whose constants are fit whose
terms the actual variables are derived
somewhat from physical intuition these
constants were then fit later by some
other folks and the references for this
are in the reading they're all in MeV
and this gives you a binding energy in
MeV for a given nucleus now it works
some places and it doesn't work in other
places yeah
that's right so this is the universal
semi-empirical
usually works formula for the binding
energy of a nucleus so yup so the
constants don't change because the
variables here are Z and a and N and
don't forget because you'll need to
remember need to remember this on the
homework that a equals Z plus n so for
example if you want to express what is
the most stable nucleus you could take
the derivative of this formula with
respect to a or Z and don't forget that
you can substitute this expression into
there that's giving you guys a hint for
the homework and let's look at what this
actually looks like as far as theory
compared to experiment so the red points
are theoretical predictions the black
points are experimental predictions and
all of the different nuclei are shown
here first of all the curve looks quite
a bit like the one that we just can wave
a Mane on the board right here and
second of all there aren't too many
exceptions it's hard to see what the
exceptions are so it's a little easier
to draw them in terms of relative error
so you can see where does this formula
work and where does this formula not so
if you notice for the small nuclei
approximating it as a liquid drop is not
a very good approximation because you
can't treat this as a as a homogenized
smeared liquid drop it's much more while
there's either two or three nucleons and
how many you know very few protons and
neutrons in each but then as you get to
larger and larger nuclei it starts to
hit very close with a few exceptions
that I want to point out right now if
you zoom in on that part you can
actually see that at certain Neutron
numbers or certain proton numbers
there's an exceptionally high stability
of a lot of those nuclei and that's as
you start to approach these what's
called magic numbers or numbers of
nucleons which say it's fill all energy
levels at a certain level and again it's
not for every nucleus as a function of
Neutron number but even drawing an
envelope around this curve you can see
that the nuclei around 80
to around 50 around 28 are a whole lot
more stable than the ones in between and
this pattern kind of repeats with larger
and larger periodicity and it kind of
looks like right here at the edge of our
knowledge of nuclei we haven't quite
gotten to the next peak yet this is
something we're going to talk about
Friday on the quest for super-heavy
elements or SHGs as you'll see in the
reading yep
closest to zero is the closest agreement
between experiment and theory so the
ones that are exceptionally stable which
are not predicted by this very simple
formula are up here at the peaks of
these magic numbers and actually I want
you to take a look right here at some of
these very small nuclei like helium four
is probably way up here somewhere all
the way over on the right it's an
exceptionally stable nucleus that is not
very well approximated by liquid drop
model because it's got four nucleons
they're all on the surface there's
nothing on the inside of a helium
nucleus let's say and then if you look
at stability trends in terms of are the
nuclei more stable if they have odd
numbers or even numbers you can graph
the two separately and look at the
number of stable nuclei that have an odd
total mass number or an even total mass
number and there's a few things to note
here one of them is that even numbers
tend to have a lot more stable nuclei
this is something I mentioned on the
second day of class if you look at the
kyuri table of nuclides let's go to
their homepage and just look at it sort
of in a color way the blue colors are
stable nuclei and you notice that every
other row of pixels here has a whole lot
more stable ones and that's what the
same thing that we're seeing right here
is that there's a lot more even nuclei
that are more stable if I jump back to
our semi empirical mass formula notice
that this binding energy goes up for
even even nuclei so when there's an even
number of protons and an even number of
neutrons the semi empirical mass formula
does predict an increase in stability
which you can actually see
on the table of new clients and on this
sort of stability trend and so let's
look a little closer and see how many
nuclei for each proton number or each
neutron number are actually stable and
we graph the odd and the even ones
separately and what's important to note
here is 1 the odd is way lower than the
even there's usually either two one or a
zero stable nuclei at that number and
what other sort of features do you guys
notice about this it's not smooth first
of all where are those Peaks where do
you tend to find the most stable nuclei
or where do you tend to find the least
what about these two right here no
stable nuclei at these proton numbers
and remember proton number uniquely
defines an element anyone know what
these two might be what sort of elements
look to the back of the room if you want
there's a periodic table on the back
wall and you can see except for the
super-heavy things down at the bottom
there's a couple of elements that have
no stable isotopes
these are technetium and promethium
which are relatively light isotopes I
say relatively light compared to things
like uranium with no stable isotopes
they're also fairly far away from these
so-called magic numbers or other regions
where you tend to have a spike in the
number of stable nuclei due to well
things that you'll learn in 2202 in
terms of nuclear shell occupancy and
stability but you see the same thing
when you graph the neutron number you
can see a couple of sudden spikes right
here at 20 28 50 82 and 126 when
everything gets really stable all of a
sudden you've got one last-gasp of a
stable isotope before you go off into
nowhere land so let's start looking at
relative stabilities of nuclei let's say
for a given mass number or a given
proton number anyone mind if I cover
this board because you can't roll it up
you all got the notes from here cool
I left to a race and I want to keep
these formulas up for our reference
let's say I post this problem I want to
find out make sure I sold the right one
actually I'm going to check my notes
real quick that what is the for a given
a or for a given mass number what is the
most stable number of protons for a
given a this is the question that I like
to answer here how would you approach
this question using the semi empirical
mass formula that well you can't see
here so I will bring it up back on the
screen here how would you find this out
well let's say for a given mass number a
for a given poor approximation of the
total mass of a nucleus the more binding
energy it has the more stable it is
therefore if you want to find the
minimum of a mass for a and Z given a
fixed a that will give you the most
stable nucleus because it will tell you
which value of z gives you the smallest
m or rather the most tightly bound
nucleus that has the most binding energy
so let's start writing this out first of
all we can use one of the two equations
we already have up here a relation
between the mass and the binding energy
the second one well we have it right
here so let's substitute in our binding
energy equation and express it in terms
of mass so let's say our mass of a
nucleus a and Z is equal to Z times the
mass of hydrogen plus a minus Z times
the mass of a neutron minus the binding
energy because in this case what I've
done right here is I've added mass to
each side of the equation subtracted
binding energy from each side of the
equation and we can just take negative
that expression and write it all out
together so we have minus AV a plus a
surface a to the two-thirds plus AC Z
times Z minus one over a to the
one-third and plus a a symmetry and
minus Z squared over a and minus Delta
so we've got one expression for the
total mass we fixed the value of a
because we're going to take some fixed
we're
atchoo some fixed value of a let's say a
equals 93 and that's the example that
I've kind of worked out in my head it so
happens that niobium has a stable
isotope at a mass of a equals 93 and we
just found out in some of our research
that niobium doesn't stick to chromium
very well that's why I've got it on the
brain so this is what I was thinking
about this morning so for a fixed a
equals 93 we want to find what is the
most stable Z how do we do that
anyone have an idea yeah differentiate
sure let's take I'll just say the
derivative of oh no it is a partial
derivative because we have two variables
here take the derivative as a function
of Z set it equal to zero this will give
us the Z number that gives us the
minimum mass for a fixed a so let's
actually do this right now so let's see
this gives us mhm and this term expanded
out is a MN minus z MN so we have a
minus MN I'm gonna make one quick
correction right here I want to make
sure everything's in the same units all
of these semi empirical mass terms are
an MeV these right here are in AMU
atomic mass units what do we have to add
in order to get these all in MeV
the conversion factor yep or in this
case we'll just stick a C squared I'll
make a little bit of room so I can stick
the C squared in there C squared now
everything's in MeV we're all in the
same units so let's say we have MH minus
MN these are in C squared and minus AV
let's see plus 2/3 a s times a to the
negative 1/3 plus I'm going to expand
this out to call it Z squared minus Z
I'm also going to stick in N equals a
minus Z so that this expands out to a
minus 2 Z squared is everyone with me
here yep I'm Darrell you're right I'm
deriving with respect to the wrong
variable thank you yep so we want to do
this as a function of Z so that term
disappears that term disappears thank
you let's work on these ones right now
so we have AC times Z squared over a to
the 1/3 so that will give us a plus AC
over a to the 1/3 times 2z and then we
have let's see minus AC over a to the
1/3 that's it actually
Oh times plus 1 ok and then we have the
a minus 2z so let's expand this out just
so we can see it all on the board so we
have a a over a times a minus 4z squared
plus 4 so minus 4 a Z
plus 4z squared so let's take the
derivative with respect to Z of that
that term goes away
that becomes 4a so we have plus a a over
a times 4a and there's a minus sign
there and that becomes 8z so we have
plus a symmetry over a times 8z and the
Delta term goes away because there's no
Z dependence and what we end up here is
the solution for what is the most stable
z as a function of a this is a linear
equation there's only one solution for
it if we actually want to graph this
function of M though this M as a
function of a and Z we end up with
what's called a mass parabola which is
to say you can graph the binding energy
per nucleon or the mass or pretty much
similar things of a nucleus of all
nuclei with a given a as a function of Z
I think I can do this on the remaining
space right here so let's say for a
equals 93 if this is Z and this is M as
a function of a and Z let's actually
look at a concrete example so let's go
live to the chart of nuclides and start
looking at things with a mass number of
93 looks like I clicked a little too
high there it is
let's see malee 93 I was looking at and
that becomes niobium 93 which is the
stable isotope I was thinking so let's
put niobium right here I haven't given
an actual scale to this because I just
want to show you in sort of relative
terms so let's say niobium is the stable
one so it's going to have the lowest
actual mass even though it's got an a
number of 93 if you look here on the
chart of nuclides
you can see it could have come from a
couple of different places either from
zirconium 93 or from molybdenum 93 and
now's a good time to start introducing
these different modes of decay so you
can figure out well how what a nucleus
decay to get to the most stable place
let's say it came from
zirconium 93 and molybdenum has a proton
number of 41 so if we go to zirconium it
beta decays to niobium 93 with an energy
of 0.09 one MeV very very close so we'll
draw it slightly higher that's about 91
KETV Serco neum 93 could have come from
the beta decay of yttrium 93 you can see
right here so let's go up the mass
parabola and keep exploring and now we
see that yet reom can decay by beta
decay with 3 MeV so if we put you trium
on this graph it would be way higher you
trium itself could have come from well
let's see strontium 93 with the decay
energy of 4.1 MeV so let's put strontium
here and I think 4 MeV would be like off
the chart but whatever that's the way we
drew it already we've got the makings of
a parabola and each one of these can
decay by beta decay or does decay by
beta decay in order to get to the most
stable nucleus so let's write the
nuclear reaction for beta decay of one
of these let's say from zirconium to
niobium so we'd have 93 40 zirconium
spontaneously goes to 93 41 niobium plus
a beta and plus an electron antineutrino
that's the part I don't expect you to
know yet but that's the whole energy
conservation thing a little bit of a
flash forward the beta decay energy is
not necessarily
the energy of the electron that you will
measure because some of that energy is
taken away by the anti neutrino but
we'll get into how those relate probably
next week so let's now look on the other
side of the parabola and confirm that
the semi empirical mass formula would
predict something parabolic here and
here with respect to Z actually checks
out so let's back up to niobium 93 and
notice that it could also have come from
electron capture from molybdenum 93 so
let's put molybdenum right here and it
decays with an energy of 0.04 let's say
0.4 MeV into niobium which let's say
it's around here let's keep going
through the chain anyone have any
questions so far well we keep going cool
let's trace it back up the chain
technetium 93 can be get molybdenum 93
by electron capture with a much higher
energy three point two zero one I'm
going to extend our graph because we
need the space technetium another three
MeV and let's go one more back
technetium can be made by electron
capture from rubidium 93 with an even
higher energy which means a higher
difference in mass between these two so
so far let's see what's six MeV for
rubidium here it would be like there I
guess
there's our mass parabola right from the
data so I like doing this better than
just showing you a diagram because you
can actually try for yourself pick a
fixed a change Z and construct the mass
parabolas yourself now the question is
how could these decay into niobium 93
which is the stable isotope we have
negative one minutes left so I'm very
quickly going to tell you for large
energy changes it can add to be positron
decay or electron capture and we'll go
over what these modes of decay are next
week
this can be again positron or electron
capture and for small amounts of decay
energy it can only be electron capture
because in order for positron decay to
happen you have to be able to create the
positron and the positron plus the extra
electron ejected to balance charge has
got to be 1.0 to 2 MeV or same thing as
what's known as 2 times the rest mass of
the electron I'm gonna stop there and
we'll pick up with lots of examples and
questions tomorrow the last thing I'll
go over the next problem set tomorrow I
want to make sure everyone's seen it 7
days before it's due and the best way to
do that is to show it on the board
you